[موسيقى]
لو ننظر للموضوع بشكل شامل وشكل تاريخي
واجبنا انه هناك فيها اتهامات وفي
انتقادات من جميع الاطراف على سبيل المثال
في هناك من يقول ان الدول الصناعيه هي
المسؤوله على الوضع اللي نزل نفسنا فيه
بسبب 120 سنه من العصر الصناعي ولذلك
عليها مسؤوليه ان تعالج هذه المشكله وعلى
الدول العالم المسؤوليه ان تعمل سواء
لمعالجه المواضيع المستقبليه هذا المنظر
هناك ايضا
همم اتفاهم حدث في اتفاقيه في قمه باريس
على انه يكون في صندوق اا بحوالي 100
مليون دولار في السنه لمساعده الدول
الناميه على التعامل مع المواضيع البيئه
والتغير المناخي وهناك كان الالتزام ايضا
لنقل التقنيه المطلوبه لهذه الدول هناك
انتقادات من قبل الدول الناميه من المبالغ
هذه لم تاتي وانه التقنيه همم لم يتم
تقديمها لهم فهذه ال ال ال ال الاخت
والعطا لازال مستمر
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه الحوار بالنسبه لموضوع التغير
المناخي
مليء بالمشاعر والعواطف
لما يكون الحوار مليء بالمشاعر
تجد في تناقضات على سبيل المثال الدول
الاوروبيه تفرض ضرائب 200% على البترول
واحد الحجج انه المناخ في نفس الوقت
يقدمون مساعدات للفحم الذي اسوا للمناخ من
البترول المنطقه
في عندك هناك مطالبات بعدم الاعتماد على
البترول والفحم
وبعد ما صارت الازمه في اوكرانيا صار في
مطالباترون هذه
المواقف المتناقضه
اساسها
الحوار الذي ليس مبني على منطق وعلى امور
علميه
[موسيقى]